Oh
so we talk a lot about how we want the
answer right we're bliss junkies chasing
the ultimate truth but think about it
aren't we more happy when we're seeking
the truth
aren't we all secretly wonder chunkies
isn't our addiction to the question
itself you know once you find the answer
you risk completion you know we talked
about wanting to find ourselves we
talked about being found but isn't it
more fun to get lost
aren't we all Wanderers ultimately
aren't we wandering aren't we seeking
why do we love open spaces wide open
spaces have more appeal than beautiful
cozy small spaces why are we look at the
infinite ocean and actually feel a sense
of reverence and awe instead of being
afraid we look at it as it beckons us to
the unknown to the mystery to the
question see that's what it's really all
about that is the state of consciousness
that we want to be at right we want to
be the traveler in search of
signification when you find that it's
all worth you know it's not about the
answers it's about the better questions
you know that quote and that's really it
that's what I'm looking for in these
spaces that's the Lord of the Ring
landscape New Zealand brochure fantasy
I'm getting lost in it
hmm only when we're lost
yes we're found all right guys so be
sure to check out our sister network
seeker where we explore travel adventure
culture and amazing stories from around
the globe as human beings exploring is
in our nature we want to learn and
discover until we are able to better
comprehend not only the world but
ourselves what is without becomes within